de que se mueren los hombres
la primera causa de muerte en los
varones son las enfermedades
cardiovasculares y las mujeres sabemos
esto porque a lo largo de la vida
cuidamos a nuestros hombres
también sabemos por qué pueden
enfermarse hace unos años ya desde un
programa que hacemos en la fundación
cardiológica argentina hicimos una
encuesta en una muestra representativa
del área metropolitana de buenos aires
de 600 mujeres y les hicimos preguntas
sobre factores de riesgos
y el 80 por ciento de las mujeres
sabía que condiciones como tener presión
arterial alta colesterol elevados ser
diabéticos o fumar son factores que
aumentan el riesgo cardiovascular
el 90 por ciento de las encuestadas
sabía que el dolor de pecho puede ser un
síntoma de infarto cardíaco y la gran
mayoría además tenía información acerca
de todas las conductas que previenen o
ayudan a controlar la enfermedad
cardiovascular
a esas mismas mujeres les preguntamos
cuál es la primera causa de muerte en
las mujeres
y como pueden ver más de la mitad del
contexto que el cáncer en general y
muchas que el cáncer de mama en
particular
pero que se mueren en realidad las
mujeres
en argentina una de cada tres mujeres
muere por enfermedades cardiovasculares
muchas más muertes que si sumamos las
que ocurren por todos los tipos de
cáncer y además por sida y además por
accidentes
es más
estos son datos del ministerio de salud
de la nación y como ven desde el año
2007 en nuestro país mueren incluso más
mujeres que hombres por causa
cardiovascular
hoy 135 y 1 en los próximos 11 minutos
yo soy médica cardióloga y desde el año
2006 tengo el compromiso de combatir dos
realidades la primera es esta sin duda
la enfermedad cardiovascular representa
el principal problema de salud que
tienen las mujeres
y la segunda es que como les mostré la
mayoría de las mujeres desconoce este
dato y tiene una percepción que difiere
de la realidad
ahora los factores de riesgo
cardiovascular son los mismos
yo digo diabetes hipertensión
sedentarismo estrés sobrepeso al
mencionarlos pareciera que sí pero esto
no necesariamente es así si hablamos de
sobrepeso no es lo mismo en hombres y en
mujeres en la mayoría de los hombres la
grasa se concentra en la panza mientras
que en la mayoría de las mujeres las
grasas se concentran en las caderas y
para el corazón pareciera ser más nociva
la distribución abdominal de la grasa
por otro lado el impacto que tienen los
factores de riesgo también es distinto
por género la diabetes por ponerles un
ejemplo ser diabético es un factor de
riesgo para los hombres y para las
mujeres si un hombre es diabético tiene
2.6 veces más riesgo de tener un infarto
que si un hombre no es diabético
pero si una mujer tiene diabetes tiene
más de cuatro veces de chances de tener
un infarto que una mujer que no tiene
diabetes y lo mismo ocurre con la
hipertensión arterial o con el
sedentarismo que aumentan la chance un
infarto mucho más en las mujeres que en
los varones y por el contrario el
tabaquismo tiene un ligero peor impacto
en los hombres que en las mujeres
y el tercer punto en relación a los
factores de riesgo es que es posible que
existan condiciones que son propias de
las mujeres y que aumentan el riesgo de
enfermarse y que no conocemos y esto
tiene que ver con que históricamente las
enfermedades cardiovasculares han sido
estudiadas en los varones y extrapolar
la evidencia que proviene de los hombres
a las mujeres puede ser un error así
como estudiar a las mujeres puede traer
sorpresas
déjenme darles un ejemplo tal vez muchos
han escuchado que las mujeres en edad
fértil
tienen
menos riesgo de enfermarse por efecto de
las hormonas sexuales una protección que
se pierde a partir de la menopausia
bueno durante muchos años muchas mujeres
fueron tratadas con terapia de reemplazo
hormonal se las reemplaza va con parches
con hormonas similares a aquellas que ya
habían dejado de tener bueno solo los
estudios de investigación que incluyeron
a miles de mujeres seguidas durante
muchos años pudieron poner de manifiesto
que el reemplazo hormonal lejos de
proteger al corazón aumentaba el riesgo
cardiovascular
a las mujeres nos mata que nos
reemplacen y esto es la evidencia
científica pero además de eso es un buen
ejemplo de que las mujeres tienen que
ser todavía objeto de estudio
la medicina hoy fundamentalmente está
basada en estos estudios clínicos y aún
en la actualidad las mujeres siguen
estando subrepresentados en los estudios
de investigación y esto es una cosa que
podemos cambiar
puedo mostrar los datos de insuficiencia
cardíaca pero podría mostrarles de
cualquiera de las enfermedades
cardiovasculares la proporción de
mujeres incluidas en estudios de
investigación en este caso con drogas
para el tratamiento de insuficiencia
cardiaca es menor al 30 por ciento
cuando en realidad hace una guerra a
toda la población que tiene
insuficiencia cardíaca más de la mitad
son mujeres
ahora al principio de la charla les
hablé de los síntomas
y quiero detenerme en esto así también
existen diferencias en los síntomas
entre los hombres y las mujeres voy a
hablar de infarto cardíaco
el síntoma típico de un infarto es el
dolor de pecho opresivo descrito hace
más de 200 años por un hombre en base al
observado de nombres y en ese entonces
leído por hombres
pero existen otros síntomas que se
llaman atípicos en contraposición a lo
típico y que son el dolor de espalda las
náuseas la fatiga la sensación de
indigestión es a priori uno pensaría que
atípico suena a raro o infrecuente
bueno casi la mitad de las mujeres que
tienen un infarto tienen síntomas
atípicos
y
es posible
que si la descripción del infarto
hubiera sido hecha en base a hombres y
mujeres a esto que llamamos atípico lo
hubiéramos denominado de otra manera
femenino
lo cierto es que
la dificultad que supone a veces está
atipicidad de los síntomas tienen
consecuencias que son muy importantes
y ocurre aún cuando las mujeres tienen
presentaciones típicas que puede ser
difícil hacer un diagnóstico por lo
siguiente un hombre entra a una guardia
con un infarto o la mayoría de ellos
diciendo esto tengo un dolor de pecho
que me aprieta como si tuviera la pata
de un elefante parado encima y todos
corremos esto es lo habitual pero muchas
mujeres hacen un relato del dolor que es
distinto algo más asociado de los
sentimientos algo como tengo una
sensación como de angustia como si
necesitara suspirar y nadie corre porque
es un relato más complejo y en un ante
un infarto es muy importante ser claros
porque lo que ocurre es que se tapa una
arteria se obstruye bruscamente el flujo
que pasa por esa arteria y deja de
irrigar se el músculo cardíaco y por
cada minuto de demora hasta que se abre
esa arteria mayor es el daño del corazón
y obviamente mayor es la probabilidad de
morirse
al minuto cuenta
algo que es el sentido común pero que
además ha sido demostrado
científicamente es que de los pacientes
que tienen un infarto los que antes
llegan al hospital son los que cuando
empezaron a sentirse mal se dieron
cuenta que efectivamente estaban tiene
un ataque cardíaco
y el darse cuenta el estar en presencia
de un cuadro clínico se construye
mentalmente por un lado con el
reconocimiento de los síntomas y por
otro lado si uno cree que lo que está
ocurriendo es posible y esto último es
viable solo si uno sabe que puede
enfermarse
déjenme contarles el caso del olivo
es una paciente a la que conocí hace
unos años cuando entro al hospital con
un infarto
y empezó a sentirse mal estando en un
taxi muy cerca del hospital y le dijo al
taxista que le llegue a la casa
para no preocupar al marido porque tenía
exámenes que corregir ella es profesora
porque como muchas mujeres sentía que
tenía algunas responsabilidades
familiares que no podía delegar porque
creyó que se le iba a pasar y porque en
definitiva nunca se imaginó que lo que
estaba teniendo era un infarto el caso
de loli no es una excepción en argentina
o un estudio que se hizo demostró que
las mujeres consultan en promedio casi
dos horas más tarde que los hombres y
esto significa menos probabilidad de
vivir
otro caso
maría una mujer que estaba en su auto en
un semáforo parada tras un camión que yo
ha congelado que no frenó y la chocó de
atrás
entonces ella se va a halo a tu día del
auto sin lesiones graves
va a ver su auto cuando ve cómo está y
empieza a discutir con el camionero y en
el medio de la discusión empieza a tener
dolor de pecho al poco tiempo llega la
ambulancia le ponen un collar de
filadelfia y la llevan al hospital en
hospitales ya entra diciendo que le
dolía el pecho y la llevan a hacerse una
serie de radiografías y tomografías para
descartar lesiones asociadas al
accidente
m
esto es meramente especulativo pero es
posible que sea no maría hubiera sido un
hombre que entraba laborde a un hospital
tras un estrés hiperagudo como el que
supone tener un accidente de autos
diciendo que le daría el pecho
lo primero que hubieran hecho los
médicos es un electrocardiograma para
descartar que no tenía un infarto antes
de llevarlo a dar vueltas por la sala de
rayos
entonces las demoras de los mismos
pacientes a consultar las demoras que a
veces tienen el sistema de salud y la
dificultad diagnóstica que a veces
supone está atipicidad de los síntomas
determina
que acá en argentina pero también en el
resto del mundo las mujeres reciban
menos tratamientos para el infarto y una
consecuencia
evitable
y el hecho de que reciban menos
tratamientos
de algún modo explica entre otras cosas
que una mujer con un infarto se muera
más que un hombre con infarto
entonces creo que es muy importante que
desde la comunidad médico-científica
incrementemos de investigación clínica
mujeres
que luego desde lo asistencial
efectivamente les brindemos les
aseguramos que van a tener el mejor
tratamiento disponible
y el resto tiene que ver con la
comunidad que podamos generar conciencia
a ustedes que son mujeres
y también ustedes que son varones
se convencen de que las mujeres pueden
enfermarse del corazón entonces esto
puede tener dos consecuencias muy
importantes la primera tiene que ver con
la prevención que las mujeres
adopten conductas saludables que
consulten periódicamente al médico que
conozcan cuál es su riesgo vascular que
los varones empiecen a cuidar al corazón
de las mujeres del mismo modo en que las
mujeres cuidamos el corazón de nuestros
hombres y la segunda consecuencia es que
ante la eventualidad de que una mujer
tenga algo bueno que rápidamente
consulte porque eso puede salvarle la
vida
hace
unos meses estábamos
estamos reunidos en una sobremesa con
amigos
yo en ese momento estaba trabajando en
una campaña de concientización y estaba
muy entusiasmada con esta idea de que
una simple campaña puede salvarle la
vida a alguien
y alguien me dijo vos no puedes esperar
que los demás sueño en tus sueños
y yo espero profundamente que el que me
la dijo esté equivocado
así que les pido a todos por favor que
nos ayuden y se comprometan a contar
esto y es que el corazón de una mujer
puede romperse en serio